this is Startalk hi I'm Neil deGrasse
Tyson I'm an astrophysicist with the
American Museum of Natural History and I
host Startalk welcome back to star talk
radio and it's fighting all these air
molecules like what's up with that we
win no you don't want to look at Venus
well you could but not with the people
because you would be crushed by the
atmospheric pressure with nearly a
hundred times that of Earth then you
would rapidly vaporize from the 900
degrees Fahrenheit for 500 degrees
Celsius temperatures it's a runaway
greenhouse effect it is hostile to
organic chemistry which therefore makes
it hostile to life you go around the
solar system Jupiter doesn't have a
surface to land on it's all gaseous same
with Saturn Uranus and Neptune but
they've got some awesome moons orbiting
around them one of them my favorite is
Europa Europa is a one of the moons of
Jupiter it's icy on the surface but the
stress from Jupiter's gravity pumps
energy into Europa melting that ice so
there's an ocean of liquid war it's been
liquid for billions of years on earth
anyplace we find liquid water we find
life so one of nasa's edict is to follow
the water maybe you'll find life I want
to go to Europa cut a hole in the ice
drop a camera see if anything swims up
to the lens and licks it yeah that so so
Europa is very high in my list there's
another moon one of the moons of Saturn
Saturn right here and it's my planet
Saturn Saturn has a moon one of the
largest moons in the solar system called
Titan Titan has an atmosphere the moon
with an atmosphere that's cool it's got
an atmosphere it's very cold so water is
completely frozen solid I mean we call
it ice but on that moon's surface it's
the bedrock of the landscape well at
those temperatures what else happens
gases that we are familiar with in
gaseous form have
liquefied there were liquid lakes of
methane methane is the gas that comes
out of your stove on Titan the methane
has liquefied the rivers of methane
lakes of methane who is to say that
there isn't life based on liquid methane
they're just as here we are life based
on the liquids available to us water so
maybe life doesn't require liquid water
maybe just life needs a liquid anything
you